on Monday evening a serious road traffic
collision happened in Snowden Road Ely
which tragically claimed the lives of
Kyrie Sullivan and Harvey Evans two
friends who live in the community of Ely
our thoughts are with the families and
friends of kairis and Harvey and
everyone affected by this terrible
incident we can only begin to imagine
the grief they are experiencing this at
this time
their families continue to be supported
and updated by Family liaison officers
I am aware of concerns in the local
community regarding the timeline of
events which culminated in the Fatal
Collision including CCTV footage which
shows a police vehicle following a bike
in Frank Road
there was no police vehicle in Snowden
Rhone at the time of the collision and
we believe there were no other vehicles
involved in the incident
we have based this on witness accounts
tracking data and CCTV
we have made a mandatory referral to the
independent office for police conduct to
ensure the matter receives independent
scrutiny
we will provide them with all the
information we have and they will
undertake an independent investigation
I will now turn to the violence and
disorder which happened in Ely on Monday
night nothing can excuse this property
was damaged and people were scared in
their own homes
our Focus now is to fully cooperate with
the iopc investigation into the
circumstances of the collision and to
investigate the appalling scenes that
followed